[موسيقى] لقد عمل
450 مهندسًا وفنيًا
بجد لمدة ست سنوات في بناء الأمل
حرفيًا هذا هو اسم هذه
المركبة
الفضائية ، مسبار الأمل الذي سينطلق نحو
المريخ في وقت لاحق من هذا
الأسبوع ، سيصنع التاريخ
كأول مهمة بين الكواكب في
العالم العربي وأثناء هذه دبي  - يمكن للمشروع القائم على
تحسين فهم العالم للكوكب الأحمر بشكل جذري ، حيث أن
مدير المشروع قد وضع نصب عينيه
أقرب إلى المنزل ،
وليس الوصول إلى المريخ هو الهدف الرئيسي هنا ،
إنه وسيلة لهدف أكبر بكثير
يتعلق الأمر بمستقبل اقتصادنا
حول إنشاء المنشور  -اقتصاد النفط اقتصاد
مبتكر وتنافسي
يعتبر النفط حجر الأساس لاقتصاد دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
حيث يمثل 30 في المائة من
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي للدولة
ولكن مع توقع أن يصل الطلب إلى الذروة في غضون
عقود ، جعل القادة
التنويع الاقتصادي أولوية قصوى
ويأملون أن تساعد مثل هذه المبادرات
لذلك عندما تعلق الأمر ببناء المهمة
، كانت الحكومة واضحة جدًا مع
الفريق
الذي أخبرونا أنه لا نبني ذلك  شرائه ،
يمكنك العمل على برنامج نقل المعرفة ،
لذا فقد عقدنا شراكة مع جامعة
كولورادو
في بولدر 15 من الشركاء الدوليين الذين
ساهموا في المركبة الفضائية المستقلة
التي ستحاول التقاط الصورة الأكثر
شمولاً لجو المريخ على
الإطلاق ، ستعمل ثلاث أدوات مختلفة على
تحليل مستويات الهيدروجين والأكسجين  لعام
مريخي كامل
لمدة 687 يومًا ، ويمكن لهذه البيانات أن تساعد
الباحثين في استنتاج سبب تحول الكوكب الأحمر إلى
غير صالح للسكن يعتقد العلماء
أنه قبل أكثر من 4 مليارات سنة
كان المريخ كوكبًا حيًا له
خصائص وخصائص مماثلة للأرض
حدث
خطأ ما هناك وتحول  إلى كوكب ميت ،
لذا فإن فهم أفضل
لما حدث للمريخ سيساعدنا
على فهم أفضل للتغييرات التي تحدث
على الأرض
[موسيقى]
إذا سارت الأمور وفقًا للخطة ، نأمل أن
يصل كوكب المريخ في عام 2021
بالتزامن مع الذكرى الخمسين
لتأسيس البلاد.
إنجاز مثير للإعجاب لوكالة فضاء
عمرها أقل من عقد من الزمان
وأكثر من 9 سنوات  0 في المائة من موظفي البعثات
تقل أعمارهم عن 35 عامًا ،
لكن أعضاء الفريق يعتقدون أن هذه مجرد
البداية ،
هذا هو العصر الذهبي للفضاء في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لذلك هذا ما بدأناه الآن ،
لذلك لدينا رواد فضاء لدينا.
وجود مهمة المريخ الخاصة بنا ،
لذا أعتقد
أنها ستنخفض مثل هذا العقد ، ستدرج
في كتب تاريخنا
لهذا العصر الذهبي لمواصلة
تشجيع الأطفال على متابعة
الدراسات العلمية
أمر أساسي ومبادرات مثل هذه يمكن أن
تساعدهم
فقط  التي أشعر بها في البداية
قبل الإعلان عن المهمة بقليل ،
كان هناك هذا النوع من
وصمة العار إذا دخلت في مجال العلوم مثل
أين ستكون مهنتك ، لكنني
أعتقد أن أطفالنا
والجيل القادم حتى ابنتي
بنفسي يمكن أن تنمو  لأعلى وأقول أنك
تعلم أنني أريد أن أصبح رائد فضاء